put on your 3d glasses now welcome to
you laughs you lose if you scatter
differ Laura YouTube favorite show of
all time I don't have any issues
uploading this at all which version are
you watching version one
perhaps version two or maybe even
version eight damn 2018 you tube socks
okay Missy f40 all the dank stuff all
the good stuff I cut out
anyway let's enjoy the show if you laugh
you lose but you can't do both
when you can't do either disgust I do
full already
let's begin a challenge let's go oh it's
good old Skyrim wow that looks a bit
strange
me too
great
well just go over right now hurry up of
the Baron Hitler confused
oh he's back you're looking a little
rough around the edges you feeling all
right yes yes I am feeling all right how
are you doing Louis la la trusts trash
can't read wow what a great clip to
start off with what else are we gonna
shut down talking action figures my idea
love it let's see what I say you eat all
my beans can we blur the the word what
do I say
[Music]
it goes on for a minute
no thank you not Scott that the rule is
simple Lao does not equal funny trust me
I know I've been unfunny for you all
right moving on
hey back what is wrong with that guinea
to this beginning it was beautiful it
was very nice
no no no no that has to be faith I mean
that looks pretty fake to be honest I
[Music]
want to do that on Edgar now yeah that's
that one it fake a lot of things that
are sleep great that's that's great you
know whatever you want to do to be happy
[Music]
[Applause]
that was nicely time dammit well then
it's the short one that always getting
me made Jesus Christ
[Music]
top 10 anime battles of 2018
angel
[Music]
okay
with that
[Music]
the crabs they have learned to walk
forward in a straight line my God we're
doomed my favorite one is still the one
with the cakes but that was pretty good
for the bushes Oh
[Applause]
and we're gonna end it there we don't
need to see more we don't need to see
more and I and it was a nice little clip
that we all enjoyed then nothing bad
ever happens because nothing bad ever
happens and bad happens our band and not
Scott that worthy gay you don't scratch
our head bad I think this would have
been funny if we would didn't give my
ears completely
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I do like smooth I love the movie edits
they're so good goddammit
the movie addicts are the best there
[Music]
[Laughter]
well I think it's time to end this
episode here
did your Scott or did you for Laura let
me know in the comments down below in
case you didn't know where the comments
were that's where they are there leave a
something and remember to always brush
your teeth but check